The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The artists tonight--
this afternoon-- are of course,
we'll start off with
Phil Scarff, Natraj,
who plays all these
saxes in front of us.
Phil is a stalwart of this area
who plays in jazz ensembles
and also tours India with his
gifts as an Indian musician,
and has just come back from
India, as a matter of fact.
And his CD-- his Indian CD--
is up on the table there.
Mike Rivard, you
probably know Mike
from several different
ensembles, especially
Club d'Elf.
He's playing bass.
Jerry Leake, white pants
over there, plays tabla
and he also plays the
various hand percussion.
He is a member of the Cubist
Ensemble as well as Natraj.
Bertrand Lehman
plays the trap sets
and other percussion
over in the corner.
They're going to open
the program today,
but Ravikiranji-- Sangeet
[? Samrat ?] Chitravina N
Ravikiran, to be
more exact-- is going
to join them on the second item.
And I hope you'll give him round
of applause when he appears.
The program today will be in
two parts, roughly an hour long
each, with a very short
intermission between,
which will give you a chance
to go and look at the many CDs
that the artists have
brought from all phases
of their careers.
So without further ado, Natraj.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - NATRAJ, "AVA DE SE"]
PHIL SCARFF: Thank
you very much.
And we opened our
program this afternoon
with a traditional
West African piece
called "Ava De Se" from
the southern Ghanaian
tradition of the Ewe people.
Once again, Jerry Leake.
On that piece he was
playing [INAUDIBLE].
Let's hear it for Jerry Leake.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And on drums and
percussion, Bertram Lehman.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And on
string bass Mike Rivard.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And I'm Phil
Scarff on saxophones.
Thank you.
Now we'd like to
welcome to the stage
our special guest for this
evening's program, Sangeet
[? Samrat ?]
Chitravina N Ravikiran.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: So we're
going to continue
with an original
composition by Ravikiran.
This is a piece called
"River," and it's
based on the Carnatic
rag [? Saraswati. ?]
[MUSIC - NATRAJ, "RIVER"]
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Thank
you very much.
Once again, that was
the composition "River"
by Ravikiran, arranged
by both Ravikiran
and me for this program.
And next we'd like to move
to a different tradition,
and we're going to move
to the jazz tradition--
contemporary jazz
tradition-- and play
a piece by the great saxophonist
and composer Ornette Coleman.
And this is his classic piece
"Lonely Woman," which was first
released on-- I believe-- Shape
of Jazz to Come back in 1959,
I think.
And so we thought we'd give this
a little different treatment
today.
This is Ornette
Coleman's "Lonely Woman."
[MUSIC - NATRAJ, "LONELY WOMAN"]
[APPLAUSE]
RAVIKIRAN: Good afternoon.
And I'd like to introduce
the next composition.
It's titled "Red Swan."
It's actually based on a
traditional composition
of Carnatic music, and based
on a very popular mode of raga
called Hamsandani, which is
well known in both North Indian
and South Indian
classical music,
but the composition has
been set for arrangement
with this group,
Natraj, [INAUDIBLE]
It's a great pleasure
for me to play with each
and every one of
my friends here,
and to play at MIT for MITHAS.
So this is going
to be "Red Swan."
[MUSIC - NATRAJ, "RED SWAN"]
JERRY LEAKE:
[SINGING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[MUSIC - NATRAJ, "RED SWAN"
CONTINUES]
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Kiran,
thank you very much.
Thank you.
That was "Red Swan,"
recomposed, decomposed,
by Chitravina Ravikiran,
arranged by Ravikiran
and me for this performance.
Thank you very much.
So you've been listening
to Bertam Lehmann
on drums and percussion.
Let's hear it for Bertram.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Jerry Leake,
tabla and multi-percussion.
Jerry Leake.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Mike
Rivard on string bass.
Mike Rivard.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And of
course our special guest
for this performance, on
chitravina we have Sangeet
[? Samrat ?]
Chitravina N Ravikiran.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And I'm Phil
Scarff on saxophones.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And of
course we are Natraj.
Thank you for coming out.
We are going to take
a short intermission.
And we're going to
begin our second set
with a piece from West Africa.
This is from the Dagomba
people of northern Ghana,
as distinct from the Ewe
people of southern Ghana.
The opening piece was a West
African piece, "Awa De Se."
That is from the Ewe people of
southern Ghana and also Togo.
And this is from the Dagomba
tradition of northern Ghana,
and it's based on the-- I would
call it the-- rhythm called
Damba [? So ?] [? Chandi, ?]
and there are two compositions.
One is called "Wolenboli" and
the other one is "Bandanya."
[MUSIC - NATRAJ,
"WOLENBOLI/BANDANYA"]
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Thank
you very much.
Thank you very much.
That was Damba So Chandi,
"Wolenboli" and "Bandanya."
Turn it over to Ravikiran.
RAVIKIRAN: I've been requested
to play a short solo piece.
This is going to be
a composition which
I'll be playing on the
tabla, just me and the tabla.
So it's going to be a
composition in seven beats,
a time cycle of seven
counts known as [INAUDIBLE].
The composer of this is
a traditional composer
in Carnatic music,
Shyama Shastri,
who lived between 1762 and 1827.
And the raga is ananda bhairavi.
It is somewhat
like a minor scale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAVIKIRAN: I would like
more of this and less
of the [INAUDIBLE], please.
[TUNING INSTRUMENT]
[MUSIC - RAVIKIRAN, "MARIVERE
GATI"]
RAVIKIRAN: Can you please
reduce the high ends somewhat?
It's like--
[MUSIC - RAVIKIRAN, "MARIVERE
GATI" CONTINUES]
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Next
we'd like to play
another original
composition by Ravikiran.
This one is called
"No Nonsense Fives,"
and it's in rag janaranjani.
RAVIKIRAN: This
piece was actually
born out of the--
against the background
that all my other pieces in five
had so much nonsense before it.
So I thought, OK, at least
let me attempt something
with no nonsense in fives.
The concept behind some of these
compositions-- some of these
are actually arranged for
Western classical symphony
orchestras as well.
We have a different arrangement
for the jazz groups like this.
Some of them are even arranged
for quartets or quintets
and chamber orchestras.
The concept of this is
melharmony Basically,
melharmony is harmony
with an emphasis
on the melodic rules of
evolved melodic systems.
For instance, the
Indian raga system
is a very highly evolved
melodic system of music.
So we do create harmony in
this-- you will actually
notice it more when we
have symphonic arrangements
presented by orchestras--
but in this kind of thing
you'll probably be able
to see some glimpses
of meloharmonic principles.
And in this we are
just going to start off
with a very short
prelude by me, and then
follow it by the composition.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - NATRAJ, "NO NONSENSE
FIVES"]
[APPLAUSE]
[TUNING INSTRUMENTS]
PHIL SCARFF: OK.
Thank you very much.
That last piece was,
again, "No Nonsense Fives."
We'd like to conclude
our concert this evening
with a composition
by Purandara Dasa.
And this one is in
rag sindhu bhairavi,
and it's called
"Tamburi Meetidava."
And we've arranged this
in such a way of-- we've
set this to more of
a West African feel.
"Tamburi Meetidava."
RAVIKIRAN: Just for
information, Purandara Dasa
lived from 1484 to 1564.
Many of his compositions,
they are traditional tunes,
but some of it has also
been tuned by other people
because some of the
original have been lost.
But he's hailed as the
father of Carnatic music.
He's had a lot of
students' lessons as well.
[MUSIC - NATRAJ, "TAMBURI
MEETIDAVA"]
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Thank
you very much.
Thank you.
That was "Tamburi Meetidava."
Thank you once again.
And you've been listening
to Bertram Lehmann
on drums and percussion.
Let's hear it for Bertram
Lehmann over there on drums.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: All right.
Laying it down on tabla
and multi-percussion
we have Jerry Leake.
Jerry Leake.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And back
here on string bass
we have Mr. Mike Rivard.
Mike Rivard on string bass.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Yeah, Mike Rivard.
And of course our special
guest of the evening,
Sangeet [? Samrat ?]
Chitravina N Ravikiran.
Let's hear it for Ravikiran.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: And I'm Phil
Scarff on saxophones.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL SCARFF: Thank
you very much.
And of course we are Natraj.
Thank you so much for coming
out this evening to the concert
and thanks so much for MITHAS
and also Art of the Improvisers
and Mark Harvey for
organizing this program today.
And we hope to see you again.
Please check us out on
the web, natrajmusic.com,
check ou our Facebook page
and like us on Facebook.
Check out the recordings on the
way out and the mailing list,
and we look forward to
seeing you next time.
Thank you.
Good night.